[Music]
hola gente how are you guys today i'm
doing fabulous so today
we got some exciting packages in the
mail
yeah so they're whoo
they're not trash
that's really smelly too because he's
throwing away some old lettuce from the
pozole that like when we had posoda the
other day we finally finished it it was
delicious i even took some to aunt
christina and also to anna and jeremy
and they absolutely loved it and that
was the first time eating pozzole too
which really surprised me because i'm
like what
have you not had persona um yeah the
packages i want to talk about today so i
got a package from morocco you guys want
to guess what it is another candle no
not another cat fountain which by the
way yeah i haven't i haven't pulled that
cat fountain out well it's just a
fountain i was using it for the cats i
got like a lot of calcium built up and
i've been way too lazy to like break it
apart make it look brand new again
anyway back to the package what do you
guys think what is it
what is it oh you can see it it's
kicking through
what is that look maya's nice curious
too you're curious too isaac um
[Music]
i'm talking about this package from
morocco do you know what it is it's like
a little chandelier
yes it's a light pendant
oh it's so pretty
so it's like handmade straight from
morocco it was crazy opening this box
because they actually nailed down every
single one so i had to like pry it open
with the hammer but i got it open
and
yeah so i bought it
for right here
it's gonna go right wait
one of these
yeah i think that that middle one right
there it's gonna go right there today
the plan is to install it we're gonna be
doing some electrical work here today
because not only are we gonna be
installing this pendant i'm also gonna
finally finish installing the rest of
the dimmers so i've already installed a
few dimmers around the house
and they're like smart dimmers too so
they connect to our phone
and i could tell like google like hey
turn off the lights or turn on the
lights or whatever yeah i've only
installed them like in our bedroom the
loft area the stairs and the hallway
upstairs and then down here for the
kitchen so it looks like this and then
it's like touch screen kind of thing
like touch and then you can like dim it
wait
turn it on
make it brighter damn it
see
so i'm gonna be installing the rest of
those
and there's quite a few that i still
have around the house i've just been
putting it off because i've just been
too lazy but before we install all this
electrical work stuff look what else
came in
shout outs to our sponsor helix sleep we
got a brand new mattress baby so we are
so excited to partner with helix sleep
because they make some premium
mattresses and bedding and they make
them customized to your needs and they
bring them straight to your door like
they did for us today
[Music]
nice workout
and it's really cool because what you do
is you go on their website you take
their helix sleep quiz and they pretty
much ask you like do you sleep alone or
do you sleep with someone else and for
me when i was taking the quiz i put that
i share the mattress with someone else
you know casey
[Music]
it's a really good thing because we are
both side sleepers and we both enjoy a
really soft mattress so based on our
results helix matched us with their
sunset luxe mattress and that's what we
have here today and i'm super excited to
finally try out a new mattress
especially from helix sleep because i've
heard wonderful things about this
company
whoa
it's soft all right
i'm going to sit on the side oh yeah
you're a side sleeper that feels comfy
let me try the other side
oh that's so comfy
got that new mattress smell what's that
smell like
yes it does just in case you're like
wait tiff i don't want to buy a mattress
that i've never tested out myself well
you ain't got to worry because helix
actually offers a 100 night sleep trial
so more than three months for you to
test it out and see if you love it and
if you don't no worries just like how
they deliver straight to your door for
free they will pick it up for you and
give you a full refund if you absolutely
don't love it join me my love three two
one
i didn't land very far up from the bed i
think we're gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
so if you're in the market for a new
mattress make sure to check out helix
take their sleep quiz see which mattress
you get linked up with and you can do
that by clicking the link in my
description or you can go to
helixsleep.comcase and you could get up
to 200 off your brand new mattress
look i broke my nail
another one when we're doing the
porcelain i broke my thumbnail and then
now it's my middle finger nail and these
are my natural nails you guys like i'm
not even
this is painful
all right so we took a really long break
i want to say we took a nap but we
didn't i was laying in bed but um yeah
every time every single moment i'm in
this video right here
that's true no but yeah so what we ended
up doing uh for a while because as you
can see it's a lot later in the day we
were eating relaxing enjoying that new
mattress and also putting off
the fact that i had to install this and
the dimmers um but yeah okay listen
we're getting into it now okay we're
gonna do it are you done yes let's do it
all right we should bring in the ladder
i hear you sign about needing to do i'm
like
i think you're gonna give yourself a
pound on the back once we're done doing
this because i think you're gonna love
it
just imagine just imagine the pendant
there i know look at that room
i know it's like it's it's naked it's
going to tie it together but then it's
going to exactly same way rugs tie a
room together the pendant's going to
time the air in there ceiling the
ceiling together yes well you get the
ladder
definitely needs a pendant here and then
for over the island here when we
purchased the home we thought that we
purchased the package that would include
the hookups for the
the pendants to be here over the island
but apparently not oh and also that
package came with the dimmers but
apparently not so that's why i had to
install my own dimmers thank you
my big strong man
[Music]
home depot it's not that bad even
contractors that come here and they're
like yo can i borrow a letter i'm like
okay here we go oh my gosh have you ever
really hey though
oh we should move the
that thing i would help but you know
it's easier if i don't
i'm just kidding
i can help with this
here i'll relax while you
man it's very good for moral support
there
you can do it with your legs crossed
like you should have an ice to your
hands too you can do it i believe in you
honey you got this i've been watching so
much downton abbey lately you sitting
there while watching me work
oh yeah i could do it oh you you want to
do this part yeah no i want to install
it okay
yeah so you take over here yeah
you can be cameraman i will be cameraman
i'm gonna have to see well first of all
we need to turn off the electricity okay
it looks like he
turned it off because i just had these
all these lights on right now and they
just turned off oh wait i got the wrong
thing but i'm gonna test
that the electricity is fully out so i
don't get electrocuted
all right
there we go
power is off
because if not this thingy would be
beeping like crazy
there we go
all right that looks like
it's ready for me to mess with hopefully
i don't get electrocuted
i shouldn't they'll see i'll beeping
why did it beep why did you beep
why did it beep and that's not beeping
anymore
moral support let me
let me cross my legs too
are you stripping this
fully closed
[Music]
all right so we got the thing up
creative i can't even see your face this
thing's gigantic but what's the problem
now
all right the problem is it's too small
for the hole that's actually been cut
out in the ceiling so
yeah yeah
so it goes into the hole and second of
all the holes for the screws don't match
the size so that's as far as we can
screw it in at the moment so we got two
gigantic bolts sticking out from the
ceiling so ugly what do we got to do we
gotta get a bigger bigger thing for that
a little a bigger crown for that guy i
don't even know
where you would get it yeah like where
where do you go a lamp place return it
to morocco why do we always have issues
with screws because they're screwing
with us
look at this kid this kid has made
himself dinner and he chose to make
himself a double serving of instant
noodles with some shabu-shabu pork i
don't know we're gonna be stuck with it
disgusting ceiling look at it it looks
like frankenstein frankenstein's neck
doesn't frankenstein's neck have a bolt
sticking out looks like your head is the
lamp now
i don't know whatever i don't care i'm
pissed i'm leaving it okay so
hey dude
cutie
okay come on fingers crossed
please
please
please work
it actually looks pretty good
oh no
oh no it didn't work
it didn't work
did not work
you wanna go turn it off again
didn't you work
for why
all right so i discovered the issue as
soon as i unscrewed it one of the wires
slipped out of this thing which is the
thing i was talking about this is where
i was connecting the two wires together
am i gonna use this i don't trust it the
freaking wire slipped out of it and
that's why i didn't work so i'm gonna
use
these guys and hopefully it works all
right we got it up again and this time i
use the little nuts so for sure the
wires are connected
please please please
[Music]
oh staff see look it's blinking that
means it's ready to be paired to my
phone ah i'm so happy it worked i
thought that was wrong i'm so happy oh
that it's blinking yeah i thought dad
was like
it works yeah i see it oh i'm so happy
oh yeah yeah that's tight
look at the little star it's like a sun
it looks like the sun looks like a
flower it looks sick though yeah it
looks romantic looks like we're about to
tango in the living room cue the tango
music we need to have our
our mint tea
oh yeah mint tea uh the moroccan style
tea i've been wanting to make that since
we came back and i haven't tried it once
you know what we went to morocco and i
came back with so much inspiration from
morocco like the tea to making tagine or
pastilla
oh that's how it is so good out there
and i've not tried to make any of those
things since coming back you really do
look like a professional tango dancer
like the way your hair is done
and then like your top it looks like
it's part of a black dress
you look like a dancer
oh man the heavy ladder yeah oh my god i
thought you were a man okay i like it
the camera is not doing this justice it
looks blown out but in person it's like
really
like dim and like seductive kind of
lighting it's really pretty but on
camera it doesn't look really good
i like it
okay but the real question is
can we live with that
i think it's gonna drive me insane i'm
gonna look for different screws
even the fact that like you could see
the black part of the ceiling is like
[Music]
her was driving me crazy so we're just
gonna have to live with it say from far
away you can't tell so it's okay yeah i
don't look at the base of the lamp oh
how i didn't know i was talking about
the base and you just walked out and the
only thing that looks
kind of stupid yeah that's just staring
along they're like what's up with that
but i mean i don't look at the base of
any lamp
uh
pendant light you just look at the
pendant that's a good point yeah so
yeah so i've got two options we either
stay here enjoy this lighting or option
two is to go upstairs and enjoy
our brand new mattress which i am very
very
interested in doing that what do you
think
there is option three and that's putting
in all the dimmers
what does your heart tell you
so we slept on the helix mattress for a
few nights now and we're both getting
the best sleep we've had in a while it's
super comfy and we'll keep you posted on
how we're liking it over the next few
weeks
[Music]
you